AND THAT YOU EVERYTHING.
MICHAEL ANTONE IS A FORMER
SENIOR NATIONAL SECURITY
OFFICIAL IN THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION, A LECTURER AT
HILLSDALE COLLEGE AND PROBABLY
THE FIRST PERSON IN THIS
GENERATION TO RAISE THE QUESTION
OF WHETHER CITIZENSHIP IS INDEED
CONSTITUTIONAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IF YOU WROTE THIS PIECE, I THINK
BEGAN THIS CURRENT CONVERSATION
THIS PAST JULY AND PEOPLE WERE
STUNNED TO FIND OUT THAT THIS
WAS NOT A SETTLED MATTER.
MOST PEOPLE BELIEVE THIS IS
ETCHED IN THE BOTTOM OF THE
STATUE OF LIBERTY BUT IT'S NOT.
>> I DO WANT TO GIVE CREDIT
WHERE CREDIT IS DUE, JOHN
EASTMAN.
A CONSTITUTIONAL SCHOLAR AND
LAWYER, HE LITIGATES
CONSTITUTIONAL QUESTIONS.
EDWARD EARLIER, DONNA REALLY
SCHOLARLY WORK.
I LEARNED THIS ARGUMENT FROM
THEM.
THEY ARE TWO OF MY TEACHERS.
BUT IT'S TRUE THAT IT HAD KIND
OF GONE DORMANT FOR A WHILE.
>> Tucker: DORMANT!
THIS IS FLAT EARTH SOCIETY STUF
STUFF.
EVERYBODY BELIEVES WE HAVE A
CONSTITUTIONAL MANDATE TO ALLOW
THE ILLEGAL CHILDREN OF ALIENS.
>> THEY BASE THAT ON A
MISREADING OF THE FIRST
SENTENCE.
ALL PERSONS BORN OR NATURALIZED
IN THE UNITED STATES ARE
CITIZENS.
THEY LEAVE OUT THE PART IN THE
MIDDLE, SUBJECT TO THE
JURISDICTION THEREOF.
THEY EITHER LEAVE IT OUT OR JUST
MEANS YOU HAVE TO OBEY THE LAW.
IF YOU ARE A TOURIST COMING FROM
ENGLAND OR CANADA OR ANYWHERE
YOU HAVE TO OBEY U.S. LAW WHILE
YOU'RE IN THE UNITED STATES.
IT DOESN'T MAKE YOUR CHILDREN A
CITIZEN OR U.S. CITIZEN.
SUBJECT TO THE JURISDICTION
MEANT SOMETHING SPECIFIC TO THE
PEOPLE WHO WROTE THE AMENDMENT.
THEY SAID IT, YOU READ THE
DEBATES OVER THE AMENDMENT.
THEY SAID IT MEANS THAT YOU
DON'T OWE ALLEGIANCE TO ANY
FOREIGN POWER, ANYONE ELSE.
YOU ARE SUBJECT TO THE COMPLETE
JURISDICTION OF THE
UNITED STATES WHICH MEANS YOU
ARE NOT A CITIZEN OF ANOTHER
COUNTRY.
IT CLEARLY DOESN'T APPLY TO
PEOPLE WHO TO PEOPLE WHO
AREN'T -- SUBJECT OF ANOTHER
COUNTRY.
THE CONSTITUTION IS CLEAR ON
THAT POINT.
THERE IS NO STATUTE THAT SAYS
OTHERWISE DECADES AGO THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH AGENCIES OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DECIDED TO
APPLY THIS PRINCIPLE AS IF
EVERYONE BIRTHRIGHT CITIZENSHIP.
WHY DID THEY DO THAT?
WHY DO BUREAUCRACIES TYPICALLY
IN OUR COUNTRY ANYWAY ACT
WITHOUT AUTHORITY?
USUALLY IT'S TO SERVE THE
INTEREST OF LIBERALISM.
WHEN THE ADMINISTRATIVE STATE
STARTS DOING SOMETHING IT'S NOT
AUTHORIZED TO DO AND NO ONE HAS
EVER TOLD HER TO KNOW YOU CAN
BET IT'S NOT DOING SO FOR
CONSERVATIVE REASONS OR REASONS
THAT BENEFIT AMERICAN CITIZENS.
IT'S DOING SO FOR REASONS THAT
BENEFIT LIBERALISM AND THAT'S
WHAT HAPPENED IN THIS CASE.
>> Tucker: HEARING THE
ARGUMENT NOW FROM THE USUAL
COURSE OF DUMB PEOPLE THAT
EVERYTHING THEY DON'T LIKE IS
RACIST.
CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG WITH THE
PURPOSE OF THIS AMENDMENT WAS TO
ENFRANCHISE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
BEEN -- AFRICAN-AMERICANS WHO
HAD BEEN ENSLAVED.
SO IN WHAT SENSE -- DOES THAT
ARGUMENT EVEN MAKE SENSE?
I WANT TO TAKE IT SERIOUSLY.
>> AS YOU SAY, THE RACIST IS
JUST A CUDGEL TO BEAT UP PEOPLE
WHOSE ARGUMENTS YOU DON'T LIKE.
SO THE 13 AMENDMENT FREED EVERY.
BEEN A CONTROVERSY AT THE TIME
WERE SOME STATES WERE SAYING YOU
CAN FREE THE, BUT WE HAVE THE
POWER TO MAKE THEM CITIZENS AND
WE ARE NOT GOING TO DO IT.
CONGRESS PASSED THE CIVIL RIGHTS
ACT OF 1866.
THE SAME CONGRESS, SAME YEAR THE
DRAFT OF THIS AMENDMENT.
THAT WAS VETOED BY
PRESIDENT JOHNSON.
THE VETO WAS OVERRIDDEN.
TWO-THIRDS OF BOTH HOUSES SAYING
FREED BLACK, THEY ARE CITIZENS.
IT ALSO SAYS NOT SUBJECT TO ANY
FOREIGN POWER.
SOME OF THE SOUTHERN STATES CAME
BACK WITH 1857, THE
SUPREME COURT RULED IN DRED
SCOTT THAT NO BLACK PERSON, EVEN
A FREE BLACK PERSON COULD EVER
BE A CITIZEN OF THE
UNITED STATES SO THE
RECONSTRUCTION CONGRESS HAD OKAY
THEN WE ARE GOING TO PUT THIS IN
THE CONSTITUTION.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO LET YOU GET
AWAY WITH THIS.
WE ARE GOING TO MAKE THIS
UNDENIABLE THAT EVERY FREED AND
THEIR DESCENDANTS ARE CITIZENS.
>> Tucker: AND AMENDMENT
DESIGNED TO ENFRANCHISE
AFRICAN-AMERICANS BEING HERE FOR
HUNDRED YEARS, 500 YEARS IS NOW
BEING USED BY CHINESE NATIONALS
AND RUSSIANS FLYING INTO GUAM OR
LOS ANGELES TO HAVE CHILDREN
HERE.
THAT WOULD BE NOT THE ORIGINAL
INTENT.
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
ONE OF THE THINGS I FIND
INCREDIBLE AND AMUSING, SADLY S
SO, THE RUSSIAN HYSTERIA OF OUR
TIME.
IT RUSSIA IS SUPPOSED TO BE THE
BIGGEST ENEMY THE UNITED STATES
HAS RIGHT NOW.
MORE DANGEROUS THAN IN THE
COLD WAR.
WE ARE SUPPOSED TO BE ON A WAR
FOOTING WITH RUSSIA AND THE
PRESIDENT IS CRITICIZED FOR
SAYING MAYBE WE SHOULD COOL IT
AND TURN THE HEAT DOWN.
HOWEVER, WE CAN'T ACT AS THE
QUESTION OF RUSSIAN WOMEN FLYING
TO LOS ANGELES AND HAVING BABIES
TO GIVE BIRTH.
THE SUPPOSE IT OF OURS, IT'S THE
TOOL TO ALLOW THEM TO ABUSE OUR
SYSTEM BY GIVING CITIZENSHIP TO
THEIR CHILDREN WHO ARE BORN
HERE, SPEND A COUPLE OF DAYS AND
THEN GO BACK.
>> Tucker: HURTING OURSELVES,
REQUIRED TO HURT OURSELVES.
>> AND OF COURSE HURTING OUR
PRESIDENT.
>> Tucker: AND AMERICA.